thank you very much for joining us we
begin in ukraine where russia's grip on
the northeast kharkiv region appears to
be weakening ukrainian troops have made
massive territorial gains in their
counter-offensive taking control of two
cities on russian supply roads russia
has withdrawn its forces saying it is
regrouping and operations at the russian
hell's apparition nuclear power plant
have been fully stopped the state agency
in charge of europe's largest power
plant says it has disconnected the sixth
unit of the plant from the power grid
let's bring in abdul hamid for the
latest on the situation in ukraine hoda
let's start with these advances that
ukrainian forces have made tell us about
the latest and how have they been able
to achieve this
well i think that's a question that many
people here
in ukraine are asking people are
startled quite happy
about this counter-offensive that the
ukrainian army has started at the
beginning of september and it's really
going at the speed of light
every day they gain more and more
territory uh but they have managed to
make also significant
breakthroughs in the russian defense
lines taking for example uh the towns of
issum and
cubias now those towns were extremely
important
for the russians because they are sort
of a hub of railways and highways and
the russians were using those town
really to resupply and i'm sort of a
logistical hub for their operation in
the donbass region so a huge blow
for the russian army one that has
actually been underlined also by russian
bloggers on the various uh social media
platforms it's a conversation that's
going on across the border as well the
question there being how did the
ukrainians manage to do that one of the
reasons is that they were they got
really over the summer some long range
mobile
rocket launchers that are highly precise
those are called the haimers and that
has really been a change if you recall
just back in july the ukrainians were at
a hold they were lacking ammunitions
they were lacking long-range weaponry
when that arrived everything has sort of
changed they swiftly sort of
built their positions and from there on
uh started
this offensive which is taking everyone
by surprise even though the defense
minister has said this is too early to
talk about any kind of victory we are
pushing uh that's because there are
still many parts of the country that are
under russian control
and you were not far from this
apparition nuclear power plant yesterday
hodder what's the situation there in
terms of of you know operations what's
been happening
well we were across the river from the
zapa regia
power plant and we talked to people in
that area and obviously the concern was
what is going to happen uh people
wondering uh you know there was all this
talk about this six reactor which was
the only one still functioning at that
point but which was disconnected from
the main electrical grid now that
reactor was absolutely essential for the
cooling down of the other five reactors
that have been shut down i think today
there is news that's going to relieve
many people
is that that overnight apparently the
ukrainians staff that is working there
has managed to reconnect that reactor to
the main electricity grid of ukraine and
are seizing this opportunity to shut
down the reactor and cool it down so it
means that at this point really the
zaparija plant is at a grinding hold
hodder thank you very much for that hoda
abdel hamid reporting there live from
dinipro in central ukraine